anyway what about you Nikki Bella is
budding romance with our Dom continue
yep it seems like Nikki has no problem
getting flirty with her Dancing with the
Stars partner at a lunch date yes on the
latest episode of total Bella Nikki and
Artem open up about their love lives
following her breakup with ex John Cena
anyway what about you know you're on a
bunch of hot women
people like CM me constantly did you get
any new news I think you were my diems
oh really I would know that oh my gosh
how much hate you I can't even like your
photos on Instagram without getting like
a crazy amount of hate so no day now
although the two have yet to publicly
address their relationship Nikki took to
Instagram shortly after news broke
posting this message that read
everything can change in just one day
what does it mean I know so many cryptic
messages do you like these two together
I kind of do and fun fact I actually saw
them out when they were on Dancing with
the Stars nothing romantic was going on
at that time yeah they just seemed like
they had a sweet friendship and I kind
of feel like the best relationships come
from friendships on Dancing with the
Stars I connected with him so much like
he became honestly one of my good
friends like Ives I spend so much time
with him that's something that I miss in
my life the last time I saw Artem I was
in a relationship for so long so I'm
just I don't know really excited to see
him today they definitely had chemistry
in my opinion maybe not romantic
chemistry but on the dance floor it was
just like sparks of course I would love
for Nikki to kind of take things slow
because she did tell her sister Brie
that she's going through a healing
process kind of a midlife crisis after
her split so do we got do we think that
their dating is a good idea
it could be a little bit soon but also
you know you have to trust your own
heart you have to trust your own
instincts they've known each other for
years and you know everything can change
in a day this is a little bit of a
surprise kind of like you were saying
she actually told et right after calling
off the engagement how she was feeling
take a look I have to man I mean I am
single but I'm I'm not ready for
mingling yet now who knew that Nicky
would be mingling with her dancing
partner I definitely didn't see it
coming but of course the doula told ET
how they leaned on each other through
that process when the pressure was on
for Dancing with the Stars this is what
happens at Dancing starts everyone
starting to crack yeah talk to me about
the therapy session well we spend a lot
of time together and they need a lot
from us and so I'm someone who when that
happens I kind of shut down but Artem
knows how to break through me and he's
really like learned how to like let my
guard down and so I he's like my Russian
therapist it's great Terminator better
yes okay so I guess we'll see how this
romance relationship all pans out be
sure to subscribe to all things et for
the latest on Mickey and Artem
yep guys until next time I'm at Kourtney
underscore teza know and KD underscore
crass and bye for now
[Applause]
you
[Music]